Blac Chyna debuts her filler-free face I
had to like come out show out and that's
exactly what she did over the weekend
stepping out in Atlanta to show off her
transformation China making her first
public appearance since dissolving her
facial filler
as John and I've been changing my life
and changing my life so
one of the things that I feel like is
going to take me to the next level is
obviously take Yosemite Shots Out China
whose real name is Angela White has been
documenting the process of going back to
her natural look it's just not
flattering it's just not what I look
like so to get back to square one she's
dissolving the filler in her cheeks
jawline and lips
it like totally changed my face and I'm
just I'm ready to get back to Angela
like Blac Chyna like black China is Blac
Chyna you know what I mean and I feel
like I've outgrown that yeah and it's
just time for like a change that's not
the only thing China's doing and what
she calls her life-changing Journey she
also underwent breast and butt reduction
surgery
oh
I'm in recovery mode right now got my
bandages on
as you can see
got my breasts reduced one of the best
decisions I could have done in a very
long time the 34 year old model says she
got her first silicone enhancements when
she was 19 years old fast forward 15
years she's removing what's left it's
really definitely uh been an experience
like I'm really like grateful as for why
China's reversing all that work trying
to set an example for my kids yeah it's
for her little ones the former reality
star shares a 10 year old son King Cairo
with Tyga and a six-year-old daughter
dream with Rob Kardashian like this part
of my life is like really important I
wanna
be with my kids don't want to have
grandkids I want to you know further my
career other things that I'm doing
and I just really feel like this is just
really holding me back you know and
hopefully it will not hold me back
anymore and I'm still on my I'm still on
my journey
[Music]